the Oscars are almost upon us and you're
probably still wondering hey why'd that
movie get snubbed I'm surprised by that
how was Bohemian Rhapsody nominated for
Best Picture you got to get over it you
got to rub some dirt on it because it's
time to move on and it's time to win
your Oscar ballot we're here to give you
all the inside information as to how to
win your pool you might be able to go
the mythological 24 424 after watching
this vid why it's not because I'm here
it's because we have to celebrated
experts here to help us with our picks
Jacqueline Coley a editor here at Rotten
Tomatoes how was picking the Oscars for
this year for you was it more
challenging than in years past or did
you find it a little bit easier going I
will say this year was slightly easier
for me just because I've been delved in
deep with awards for the entire season
here at Rotten Tomatoes I've kind of
taken that mantle onto myself also a lot
of the category shook out pretty well
from what I thought they were gonna be
so I'm not gonna lie there wasn't as
many surprises as I thought once the
nominations came out that's what I said
these two have been doing the research
all year long you two have been to more
film festivals than Dom Perignon it's
got mance you found it easier this year
as well well I'd like you you know
covering award season for the last six
months I will say that there were
certain categories especially in the
acting categories that were a no-brainer
but when it came to Best Picture that
was that that was a little tougher and
that's a good thing cuz the last prize
of the night is presentation and that's
what we're saving it for is our last
category as well so here's how it's
gonna work if you check out the bout
that we have made for you we're gonna
start with the best supporting
categories and we're gonna work our way
down that ballot and then we're gonna
close out with our grand finale the date
for you that's actor actress director
and ultimately the best picture and I
want to hear from the experts I'm just
here to referee and maybe break a tie
because I believe in Jack when I believe
in Scott
maybe they agree with each other a lot
but in the case that they don't in any
particular category I'll hear both
arguments and then I will make the
ruling and that is what is going on my
ballot hopefully I finally get to beat
my mom in the Oscars vows and it's never
happened before but with you two at my
side I feel a little bit more confident
so enough talk enough preamble let's get
right into and Jacqueline I want to kick
off with you
Best Supporting Actress which way is
gonna go I mean
I'm so glad that this is the first
category because it's also the most
honored performance of the year and
that's Regina King and if Beale Street
could talk she's just racked up every
critics win Hollywood Foreign Press the
Film Critics associations I I cannot say
enough about the fact that she's
absolutely gonna win for a performance
and it feels she could talk that one
feels like a slam dunk to me too so
Regina King Scott we're off and running
let's get the best supporting act toward
well just like Supporting Actress a slam
dunk this is going to be Herschel Ali
for green book a more fully realized
performance than the oscar-winning role
he did in moonlight two years ago but he
won the golden bulb
he won the SAG Award won the Critics
Choice he won every other award it's his
to lose it's his to lose for a green
book and I want to stick with you as we
move on to our next category with
original screenplay how's that one
shaking off sticking with green book on
are you gonna vote for Green Book for
every category I got I wish I could but
I am NOT if we want to see the Oscar
ballots one here and I think that more
than Best Picture I think that book
green book has the best shot of winning
in this original screenplay especially
because it did win at the Golden Globes
and it did win the PGA Award for Best
Picture which will help boost its a
minimal screenplay chances very tough to
conjure a screenplay out of thin air
Jacqueline but it's also tough to adapt
something that was not originally meant
for the big screen into a screenplay so
for the adapted category how's that one
going so this is gonna be a Legacy Award
it's gonna go to Spike Lee for black
clansmen Spike Lee has a long and
storied history with the Academy they
didn't nominate do the right thing for
Best Picture he didn't get nominated
this is his first year to get nominated
as Best Director I don't think that
category is gonna shake out as well but
I do think he's gonna get it for adapted
screenplay
even though in my heart I wish it was
another I know it's going to spike it's
good to hear that black clansmen is
gonna get some recognition more on that
when we get the best picture maybe I'll
have some things to say now let's move
on to the Animated Feature I think this
is one that a lot of people are looking
at and maybe it's surprising if you
haven't been following the movie
industry but people in the know no one
movie's taking this oh one movie is
definitely taking the stand with a great
power comes great responsibility
and that's why spider-man into the
spider verse is going to win Best
Animated Feature it has won every other
animated award for which it was
nominated for it won the Golden Globe if
won the the Producers Guild Award for
Best Animated Feature and it won all set
any awards which it was nominated for
including Best Animated Feature I don't
want to jinx anything but this is
running very smooth as we move into the
Best Documentary Feature Scott manse how
you feeling RBG all the way
RBG for Scott Jacqueline I picked free
solo Nat Geo produced this amazing
documentary about a man who basically
does this incredible climb with no like
safety net it's basically death-defying
you basically watch his preparation for
what could be his death I do think the
Academy is gonna go a little bit more
than that than what Scott picked for RBG
knowing with RBG because I feel like
this is especially now that three
identical strangers and won't you be my
neighbor two of the documentary
frontrunners weren't even nominated that
really opened the door for Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg who's just she is a
superhero for everything that she stood
for and stands for it's a more important
film and that's why I think that's gonna
win so I will just harken you back to
one thing which is last year Icarus beat
faces places and that was the one that
everyone thought it was gonna win and
the reason why it beat it
you got to think about which one did
people see a lot in the theater don't be
wrong
RBG was something that a lot of people
saw but free solo had this huge IMAX
push and it's actually back in theaters
right now right when people are about to
do their voting I do think this one's
gonna push and they're doing a huge
campaign to make it happen I've listened
listened free solo is back in theaters
at the moment is breaking box-office
records as it should but it's gonna end
up the most box office documentary of
the year but Ruth Bader Ginsberg she's
still with us this is a movie that
honors her at the same time that on the
basis of sex a narrative feature also
honors her she's got so much momentum
and because most people had never heard
of her they did now because of this man
I would say RBG is the more important
documentary of the two to go check out
but look at been to Yosemite I've
witnessed El Capitan didn't see any
bears but I definitely couldn't imagine
anybody scaling that thing in free solo
you get to witness it and so Scott I'm
sorry your movies very important I'm
going with Jaclyn I'm going with the
IMAX I'm going for the box office I get
a solo is the one to check off on your
ballot and we move on to Best Foreign
Language Film Scott which one you got
for this go with Cold War for foreign
language Cold War Jacqueline how you
feeling I feel like that's a
a choice I love that film but it's going
to roma roma Roma has not lost a contest
this year that it has been going up
against Cold War except for the contest
where it wasn't eligible there's no way
this is not yeah it's just there's no
way it's not happening
okay here's why it is gonna happen
here's why I'm pushing for it to happen
here's why I think it will happen the
Oscars are a different beast entirely
you have marina de tavera surprisingly
nominated for Supporting Actress no
what's all that coming but now that Roma
is the front-runner and will get the
best picture but I have to mention
because it is the frontrunner for the
big prize
and because Alfonzo Quran is the
frontrunner for directing but Cold War
was also nominated for Best Director so
I think they're going to give Roman the
big prize and give foreign film to cold
war I think it is that a traditional
studio I'd agree with you but there is
still a huge Netflix bias in the Academy
a lot of them look at the heralding of
dark times for the film industry and a
lot of them look like I don't want it to
win Best Picture
so let me give it for this just as many
people who I think are trying to do it
you're doing it spread the love there's
way more of them that are like yeah you
can't sit with us yet I'm just saying so
you're thinking it there's a situation
where it could be a makeup call perhaps
right in your opinion just because like
if a director it got snubbed but they
nominate the movie for Best Picture like
a fantastic Argo situation or a Bradley
Cooper star is born but but Marco again
what I think is really going to tip the
scales in favor of foreign film for cold
war is the fact that its director was
nominated for Best Director so there's a
lot of love for the yeah same thing
happened to hanky and he lost for more
there's a lot of love for the movie and
I have a lot of love for my panelists
equally I hate to make you over to in
these arguments but look if I'm sitting
down and looking at it it's so hard for
me but to think about the fact that Roma
could win best picture but not win Best
Foreign Film so I gotta go roma so I
think that's the one you all should
check off on your boxes I'll let you
cool down and we'll go back to
Jacqueline for the next I'm just saying
if you're with me you might have a good
chance I'm just saying I see the
oscar-winning ballet
Jaqueline let's talk best original
score' how's the the music one chicken
oh my god I'm so excited for this one
and I hate to say it and the most reason
why excited is Justin Hurwitz is not in
this category for first man so my boy
Nicholas Patel for if Beale Street could
talk is gonna finally get his due that
was a big shock on nominations mourning
the fact that Justin Hurwitz who kind of
swept a lot of the categories he won be
FCA he won that one the Golden Globes
didn't get it on here it really opens up
the door from Nicolas Patel who's the
only other composer this year to really
get a ton of love I really love all
these scores I would love it if black
panther won but put your money on a
field street guitar well Scott I'm not
sure how to feel about maybe not seeing
any original songs performed during the
actual ceremony but one is going to take
home an Oscar which one is that going to
be well breaking news all five songs now
will be performed at the Academy Awards
yeah if Kendrick decides to show up I
mean let's be honest the rap the rap God
doesn't necessarily like to show up for
stuff like this we'll see but in this
case I think you're gonna see Bradley
Cooper and Lady Gaga performed the
oscar-winning song that is shallow and I
think when you look at the other
nominations here not only this is one is
shallow the one that everybody knows
whether they've seen a star is born or
not it is it's been winning every award
that it's been nominated for there's
very few locks that's a lot and they had
the the opportunity like no other Best
Original Song where Bradley Cooper could
hop on stage with Lady gaga at any
concert and just be like oh yeah hey
Oscars remember us I think that's the
one as well so let's stick with you and
let's talk about sound edited sound
editing if there's any film where sound
was a narrative force where it was a
character in the film I mean it's right
there in the title a quiet place the
movie made 341 million dollars worldwide
it's one of the best reviewed movies of
the year and what they did would sound
in that film is more groundbreaking than
any other nominee in this category okay
Jack and I know you agree with that one
so let's go to sound mixing what's your
pick for sound mixing
so for sound mixing I'm actually picking
Black Panther on this one and I will
tell you why and it's a controversial
pick but this is one of the ones where
I'm saying you got to make the bet you
play to win the game and yes the safe
money is on first man but I'm looking at
first man in the
thing you can look as far as this film
from when it came out at Telluride and
at Venice till now people don't like it
as much as you would figure there's a
lot of people that are lukewarm look at
the snub from Damien Chazelle look at
the snub from Justin Hurwitz it's just
not a movie that's on top of people's
minds and so I do honestly think it's
gonna be like baby driving remember baby
driver was that movie that kind of fell
off it had the momentum it was nominated
for sound mixing sound editing and it
lost both Scott are you taking black
panther are you going Hersman I'm
sticking with sticking with first man
everything I agreed with everything you
said but I still think that there is it
is going to show something I mean
they're they're not a whole lot of
people love the film but there are there
was a lot of support enough support for
where I think it will win for sound
mixing it's a tough call because I think
that Black Panther I think Black Panther
is a good shot to win Best Picture and
more on that later in the vid if Black
Panther does not win Best Picture I feel
like a lot of voters want to reward
Black Panther with something and I feel
like first man the box office results
the snubs that we had already mentioned
I feel like everything is trending Black
Panthers way so unfortunately do have to
take Black Panther in there so I would
say check that one huh I will I will add
this I'm glad you picked me but again
not to change my pick because I believe
in my pick there is a lot of safe money
in first man so if any of you guys want
to be risk takers to make that bed and
maybe have a win big maybe you go that
way but I still think I have the right
choice well let's go back to Scott
Ferrara category I know he is an expert
in and that would be makeup and hair
stylist yes I am absolutely an assertive
a stylish again today I want to think
about makeup and hair style and this in
this category here I mean look at last
year with Gary Oldman his oscar-winning
performance in darkest hour the makeup
and hair styling that he disappeared
into that role the same way that Krishna
bill disappeared as Vice President Dick
Cheney in Vice it's his it is his it
it's his I am 99% sure on that one but I
still have love for border that's one of
the greatest troll fairy tales you will
ever gets a chance to see so love for
border but it's gonna go to vice so the
box you're checking for that one is
advice and we move on to costume design
Scott what's your pick for costume
design black panther and jacqueline so
I'm going with the favorite and it
breaks my heart because Ruthie Carter
who is nominated for Black Panther would
be the first african-american woman to
win the category I think she absolutely
deserves the category if no one will be
happier than me if I'm wrong about this
but sandy Powell is nominated twice for
the favorite and for Mary Poppins
returns and period piece costuming is so
hard to beat there have been so many
instances of really great fantasy sci-fi
costuming that is lost to the period
peace drama and I'm feeling that it's
probably gonna happen again this year if
she wasn't nominated twice in the same
year I would be like no but I think a
lot of the folks are gonna look at it
like she's got too much up there not to
give it to her where Scott could that
double nomination maybe split some votes
because I tend to lean towards your pick
with black man all right here's why I
think Black Panther is the one to be
here because it got seven nominations
Best Picture but all the other
nominations are below the line while I
don't think that sound mixing is is the
one that it's going to go to the way
that this movie created a whole other
world with Wakanda that was supported by
the costume design the movie made 1.3
billion dollars worldwide it's like the
Lord of the Rings and the way that it
created is of the world and that comes
from among other things cos of design
okay I agree with you on that but before
Return of the King I believe all of the
Rings lost every time they were
nominated they did yes but they did but
the last time they want for Return of
the King it was for all three films true
that I agree with Jaclyn nobody would be
happier than me if Ruthie Carter won for
Black Panther and Jacqueline I think
she's going to win for black Scott
congratulations you get a nod from the
judge I will be so happy if I'm proven
wrong about this I just want to add that
out for the record so Scott let's
continue on with our 2019 Oscar ballot a
perfect bow to my opinion so far it is
with cinematography
well I think this is definitely a roma
category you know hands down sight
unseen but it has one if one the the
Golden Globe and it won the Critics
Choice in and a lot of the
cinematography award yeah yeah so that's
why I mean just the support of that
guild in this category it's it's a
shoo-in ok good so if you're playing
along at home if you're in an Oscar pool
Roma's Andy
you check in that one so we move on to
production design Jacqueline okay so
this is one where I do think Black
Panther is gonna come out on top because
we will have an african-american female
when the category for the first time
when Hannah Bleeker the genius behind
Beyonce's lemonade I have to put that
out there every time is going to win
production design the throne-room of
Wakanda is like highlight reel and the
Oscar goes to no way that's not gonna
okay I'm gonna stick with you for film
editing who's your pick for film editing
so this one it breaks my heart because
I'm you're heartbroken oh it is this is
the reason why is because these are not
my favorites but Bohemian Rhapsody is
gonna win and the reason why it's gonna
win there's been a lot of videos on
Twitter mocking the editing and Bohemian
Rhapsody but it wins for the Live Aid
sequence that's all most people see for
the nomination process they only show
them certain clips all they do is show
them the side by side of Live Aid what
they did in the film and the live aid
actual shots and the precision editing
that they did to make those things look
almost exactly the same that's the
reason why it's gonna win you are so
convincing in your argument that my
original battle pick of Vice is now
being changed I'm going with Bohemian
Rhapsody No Mas Manson backing down yeah
I mean I mean it really is I agree with
you because like people have been
mocking it and I agree with the mockery
but they show them that Live Aid
sequence and they vote they vote for it
but also when you look at the way they
recorded Bohemian Rhapsody that scene
where they recorded the song and also
when they they cut back and forth with
we will rock you between the studio and
the concert
that's marvelous editing yeah all of the
music video sections is why this one's
gonna win and that sequence it felt like
you were there at live 8 even though
there were some visual effects employed
not enough perhaps to get it nominated
for Best Visual Effects so do we have a
agreement here Scott who's your pick for
best visual effects
he's got first man what do you have Jack
so I'm actually gonna go with Avengers
infinity war on this one I this is this
one image where I'm like the Academy of
five years ago Scott I think you're
absolutely right that first man wins but
they have been infusing the Academy with
younger voters with more actors with
more people from marginalized
communities I think this is where
they're gonna give their love for the
movie that they saw at the box office
with the fenders
these guys are friends with the film I
mean half of Hollywood's in the movie so
I do think they might give it to it and
again there's this other thing that's
bubbling under the surface which is the
motion capture performances that don't
get recognized currently by the Academy
there's a lot of people that want to
give it to that first man is traditional
visual effects this is that visual
effects that people want to see honored
soon I agree with you I mean go if Josh
Brolin's performance is status in
Avengers infinity war it was a great
performance by any measure let alone a
performance capture performance but
first man is so great with this visual
effects you take it for granted what
Dana Gisele and the filmmakers did with
that movie especially the whole sequence
with Gemini 8 where you're inside the
cockpit the whole time before it starts
tumbling in over end I mean it is a
milestone film whether or not people
were able to appreciate or could could
really get the the approach of that
movie you know this was an intimate
movie about a universal achievement but
I think that that's you know on which 78
but we'll give the oscar for for visual
I I went into this on the team of
Avengers infinity war and I think I'm
leaving here on the team of first man
simply because in the same way that you
can show a group of voters the Live Aid
sequence at the end Bohemian Rhapsody
you show them the end sequence of first
man and that might be enough to do it I
think first man does end up getting an
Oscar and no love for solo a Star Wars
story in the hyperspace now I will say
this though I'll add a little bit to
this um if it turns out whoever wins
between the two of us bases our pick
we'll give you an idea where the Academy
is because remember the Academy is going
through this really weird growing pains
I think this is gonna be a telltale sign
as to how the Academy now votes changing
its changing Academy yeah in the last
two years it has increased its
membership by a third a lot more a lot
of younger people a lot gender-balanced
are trying to establish that diversity
they're trying to establish that and of
course that does have a massive impact
on who's gonna win at the Oscars so we
move on to Best Documentary Short
subject these are always the ones that
everybody at home you feel that you're
about and you're like I didn't see any
of these I didn't get an opportunity so
Jacqueline how are we supposed to vote
for documentary Short subject so I will
admit I've seen a few of these not all
of these but the main reason why I
picked the very first one I picked which
is period
if sentence is the person that's behind
it the most powerful campaigner in the
history of the Oster's Lisa Tabak who
used to work for Harvey Weinstein
that's her movie that one's winning
sorry I don't care what anyone else says
so for short subject documentary period
end of sentence which talks about
basically the D criminalization of
menstruation in India because they have
no way for women to basically find
health care products the second one I'm
going to say is skin which is a short
film live action a lot of people also go
with Marguerite but I'm gonna go with
skin okay so Jacqueline she's in the
know she's seen a number of these that's
the way she's picking and I would
encourage everybody out there to side
with Jacqueline in that we moved a short
film animated Scott and you have a beat
on one of those anime it's gonna lose
best feature to spider-man sorry
Incredibles too but when it comes to the
animated short I think bowels the one to
beat I mean bow the short was better
than the feature film Incredibles to the
followed it it is a Pixar movie these
shorts tend to go to Pixar movies and
oftentimes the animated shorts that
Pixar does are sometimes better than the
feature films so it's all about that
bow bow pout it's been fun listening to
the documentary short subject or the
animated short because we've been
talking about that for about a week now
we get into the races this is the top
for the ones that we've been banning
about since before the Oscar nominations
were announced Scott Matz Best Actress
in a leading role
who gets the Oscar this okay it is it is
a long time coming she is long overdue
seven Oscar nominations
she has three Tony Awards three
Primetime Emmys three Golden Globes this
is going closest year for the wife and
I've been saying for a long time now
oh she's overdue she's overdue but you
know what on the merits of that
performance she deserves it it is a
great movie she is fantastic in this
role it is a career topper you know she
won the Golden Globe for this she won
the SAG Award for this she she tied at
the Critics Choice but she's still won
it's it's quite close it ain't sports
you're still gonna try cannot wait I
cannot wait to see her take that stage
what that what the walk over to Oscar is
I think that I can paraphrase a Glenn
Close role from the past and saying that
this year at the Oscars Glenn Close
won't be you know I'm not gonna be
ignored I knew you were gonna say that
same pale attractive number
time Jack when Koli we go to Best Actor
in a leading role is it as clear-cut as
the Glenn Close pick it's more clear-cut
than I would like it to be it's gonna go
to rami malek for Bohemian Rhapsody I
may have issues the narrative a still
currently sits at 62 on the tomato meter
one of the lowest ranked nominations for
both acting and Best Picture but
everybody loved his performance as
Freddie Mercury they are going to ignore
all the controversy around the film as
far as the director and the directors
history and replacement and they're
gonna give it up for Rami
he is beloved within the actors branch
and also okay its lowest rated in the
tomato meter but it's the second highest
grossing movie to be nominated for Best
Picture
more than 800 million dollars worldwide
you know this has been going back and
forth between rami malek and Christian
Bale and Christian Bale did win two
Critics Choice Awards for acting in a
Comedy and Best Actor for vice but I
think a lot of this you know you said
how Romney is beloved so is Freddie
Mercury Dick Cheney not so much so check
the box that says rami malek for Best
Actor we move on to the Best Director
who made a motion picture in the year
2018 for the 2019 Oscars Scott mance
Jaqueline Kohli what's taking home the
directing prize yeah again another
example hasn't lost yet
Spike Lee got a standing ovation at the
DGA 's when he went up to accept his
nominations because for them the
nomination is kind of like a win and he
still lost to Alfonso well and Spike Lee
he will win in the the screenplay
category but if the thing about afonso
and this is very interesting to point
out that when Alfonzo wins this Oscar
since 2013 when Alfonso won for gravity
then two years for the the two years
after that Alejandro and URI - won Best
Director for Birdman and for the
revenant
then you have okay you know like guy
Damien Chazelle for lala land but then
you're back to a Mexican director with
Guillermo del Toro for the shape of
water so that means that five times out
of the last six years the Oscar for Best
Director will go to a Mexican filmmaker
yeah foreign-born - there we go well
pick in these major categories has been
a piece of cake so let's just move on to
the last one and call today the best
motion picture this is the last award
they give out of the Oscars it's the
last one that we're telling you how to
vote in your Oscar pool what's taken
home Best Picture spider-man no we both
are gonna go for a risky choice with
Romo now I'm gonna put this out there
both of us think Rome is gonna win but
right now at this moment there are still
some Awards still to be handed out this
is the most up in the air Best Picture
race that we've had in a while because
in the sense of like okay yeah a couple
you know moonlight and lala land but
that was a two horse race we're talking
spotlight and revenue that's a two horse
race there is a legitimately four films
that could honestly take home Best
Picture and none of them would be
surprising
maybe even five roma green book Bohemian
Rhapsody black panther or black Klansmen
all have a more than reasonable shot at
taking if I had a vote I would say black
clansmen but I think that that one is
way back in the pack I think Black
Panther all of a sudden with all the
goodwill all the press that's getting
recently actually in is now the
front-runner so I have to disagree with
both y'all I'm not telling you that's
the box to check because I trust these
two more than I trust myself but I think
Black Panther has a legit shot to
outshine Romo absolutely it has a legit
shot by it and I know why you're saying
that because upon the SAG Award for best
acting ensemble and it is an ensemble
film it's not just about Black Panther
you know you've got diversity and gender
equality and all the ranks of the
casting of that movie that deserve to
win best at best guess at the sags but
you know Romo is going not only is it
right now the first Netflix movie to be
nominated for Best Picture it's going to
be the first Netflix movie to win at
least at a back who you mentioned is
doing the PR for this I have never in my
28 years of working in this business
seeing the kind of marketing and PR push
that Romo has been getting it played in
theaters which is something that Netflix
didn't do before but they bend the rules
for this for Alfonso it's it has been
winning a lot of other other awards from
yes I mean again the most still tops our
awards leaderboard I think currently now
at 60 plus wins that at Rotten Tomatoes
calm the most honored film of the year
just as Regina's the most honored
performance the one thing I will say
about any of these films
whatever wins Best Picture I can tell
you this now it
we'll come down to what we call the
preferential balloting for those of you
that don't know the Oscars don't vote
like a straight this is how many got the
most votes a film has to get 50% to win
and at this point I don't think one of
these films is guaranteed to get 50% and
so then it'll go to okay what did you
vote for you're number two because they
will ranked every one of these films
from 1 to 8 and I do think that whatever
ends up winning is gonna be the film
that more people had in that 2 3 4
ranking not just the one that maybe had
the most number one votes that's also
how jamón might want that's also why in
a lot of years in recent years Best
Picture and Best Director have gone to
different movies now having said all of
that Roma's gonna win ok look if I'm
going my heart I'm saying black Klansmen
I'm going with my soul I'm going Black
Panther but I trust y'all if you're
watching this check off Romo in the box
next to Best Picture and that's gonna do
it for us here today did 24 categories
up 24 it down I hope everybody out there
had a great time not just watching this
but playing along and voting reminder
you can check out our ballot at Rotten
Tomatoes calm where you just go to the
link in this video script and while
you're there
comment leave us a comment let us know
what do you think about these picks what
do you think is gonna take home the top
prize at the Oscars for 2019 honoring
the film of 2018
I want to thank Scott mance and
Jacqueline Kohli for helping me out here
today mom I hope you were not watching
because this is the year Mark Ellis
takes home the prize and our family
Oscar pool we'll see y'all soon